This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The 1997 blockbuster film Titanic is remembered for many things. This Celine Dion song that was everywhere. The sheer scale of the production. its record 11 Oscars, the names of its two main characters. But in real life, the actual Titanic, the one that sank on April 15th 1912, is mainly remembered for something else. So much so that James Cameron's script couldn't not mention it. I did this some in my head and with the number of lifeboats times the capacity you mentioned Forgive me, but it seems that there are not enough for everyone aboard
这里是《99% Invisible》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。1997年的大片《泰坦尼克号》因许多事物而被人们铭记。比如这首无处不在的席琳·迪翁的歌。比如制作规模之宏大。比如它创纪录的11项奥斯卡奖，以及两位主角的名字。但在现实生活中，真正的泰坦尼克号，那艘于1912年4月15日沉没的船，主要是因为另一件事而被人们记住。以至于詹姆斯·卡梅隆的剧本不得不提到它。我自己在脑子里算了一下，用救生艇的数量乘以你提到的载客量，请原谅，但似乎船上的人数并不够。
But half actually. Rose you miss nothing do you? There are countless films about the Titanic most of them called Titanic in almost all of them, the lack of lifeboats is kind of the whole point. We have lifeboats. We must launch them at once. Get everyone off the ship. That won't be entirely possible. They say it's nothing, but they're lying. There's water below. And now somebody says there aren't enough lifeboats for the men. Even the Nazis took time away from the war in 1943 to discuss the matter of lifeboats in their own Titanic film, Titanic.
实际上只有一半。露丝，你什么都没错过，对吧？关于泰坦尼克号的电影数不胜数，其中大多数都叫《泰坦尼克号》，在几乎所有的电影中，救生艇不足都是核心议题。我们有救生艇。我们必须立即放下它们。让所有人撤离这艘船。那是不可能完全做到的。他们说没什么大不了的，但他们在撒谎。下面有水。现在有人说救生艇不够男人用的。甚至连纳粹在1943年也从战争中抽出时间，在他们自己的泰坦尼克号电影《泰坦尼克号》中讨论了救生艇的问题。
The Titanic lifeboat narrative is so ingrained in our collective consciousness at this point that when I informed my dad that I was working on an episode about the Titanic, before I had a chance to say anything more, he just blurted out, ah, yes, if only they had carried more lifeboats. That's 99PI producer Joe Rosenberg. Because film or no film, it's just something we've all grown up learning, that when the RMS Titanic set
泰坦尼克号救生艇的叙事在我们的集体意识中已经根深蒂固，以至于当我告诉父亲我正在制作一期关于泰坦尼克号的节目时，我还没来得及多说，他就脱口而出：“啊，是的，要是他们带了更多的救生艇就好了。”那是99PI的制作人乔·罗森伯格。因为无论有没有电影，这都是我们从小就学到的东西，那就是当泰坦尼克号启航时……
out on its maiden voyage, the owners and authorities, confident that the ship was unsinkable, did not require it to carry a full complement of lifeboats. So when the Titanic collided with an iceberg and sank in the frigid waters of the North Atlantic, roughly 1,500 passengers, more than half of the people on board, died for lack of lifeboat space. And look, it's true there weren't enough lifeboats for everyone on the Titanic. It's also true that ever since, international regulations have required large passenger ships to carry enough lifeboats for all on board.
在它的处女航中，船主和当局确信这艘船是“永不沉没”的，因此没有要求它携带足额的救生艇。所以当泰坦尼克号撞上冰山并沉没在北大西洋冰冷的海水中时，大约1500名乘客，也就是船上超过一半的人，因为缺乏救生艇空间而丧生。听着，泰坦尼克号上确实没有足够的救生艇，这也是事实。同样真实的是，从那以后，国际法规要求大型客轮必须携带足够船上所有人使用的救生艇。
But the more you learn about the history of lifeboats and how they worked, the more you realize that the standard story about Titanic's lifeboats isn't entirely correct. For most of human history, the onboard lifeboat you are likely picturing in your head right now did not exist. A ship might have a boat, but it wasn't there to save lives. Even as late as the 18th century, on a typical wooden sailing ship, what few boats were on board were mostly for taking cargo and a few crew members to and from shore. But there were no boats for the whole crew to get on just in case the ship sank.
但你对救生艇的历史及其运作方式了解得越多，就越会意识到关于泰坦尼克号救生艇的标准说法并不完全正确。在人类历史的大部分时间里，你现在脑海中想象的那种船载救生艇根本不存在。一艘船可能会有一艘小艇，但它并不是为了救命而存在的。即使到了18世纪，在一艘典型的木制帆船上，船上仅有的几艘小艇大多也只是为了运送货物和少数船员往返于岸边。但并没有供全体船员在船只沉没时逃生的救生艇。
For starters, there wouldn't have been any room. Decks in the Age of Sail were busy crowded places with lots of gear and rigging. If Jack had tried to pull that King of the World crap on a British man-o-war, he would have been shoved overboard. So if your ship did sink, there wasn't much you could do. You might try to signal for help by firing a cannon or lighting a fire and hope that someone came to your rescue. But for the most part, things were very improvisational.
首先，根本没有空间。在帆船时代，甲板是繁忙拥挤的地方，堆满了装备和索具。如果杰克试图在一艘英国战舰上耍那种“世界之王”的把戏，他早就被扔下船了。所以如果你的船真的沉了，你也没什么办法。你可能会尝试通过鸣炮或点火来发出求救信号，并希望有人来救你。但在大多数情况下，事情是非常即兴的。
Did crews in the early modern period train or organize for sinking scenarios? What would have been the standard procedure, if anything? Trained, I think is probably too strong a word. Right. And so was it every man for himself or was it... It would depend on how well you got on with your shipmates, I guess. Helen Doe is a maritime historian who has written about the early history of lifeboats in the UK.
在近代早期，船员们是否会针对沉船场景进行训练或组织？如果有的话，标准程序是什么？“训练”这个词可能用得太重了。没错。那么是各顾各的，还是……我想这取决于你和船友们的关系如何。海伦·多伊是一位海事历史学家，她撰写过关于英国救生艇早期历史的文章。
Helen says that most shipwrecks actually occurred near shore. But even if someone on shore saw your distress signal, you couldn't always count on the lousy landlubbers to save you. Yes, there were many daring and heroic rescues, but sometimes the locals either didn't have any boats or took one look at the rough seas and thought, you know what, I'm good here. Given the odds involved, the only real strategy when it came to maritime safety was not to
海伦说，大多数海难实际上发生在近岸。但即使岸上有人看到了你的求救信号，你也不能总是指望那些笨拙的旱鸭子来救你。是的，确实有许多大胆而英勇的救援，但有时当地人要么没有船，要么看了一眼汹涌的海面就想：你知道吗，我还是待在这儿吧。考虑到这些几率，海上安全唯一的真正策略就是不要……
sink. No one gave much, if any, thought to how to save lives once you started sinking. And let's also remember that there was a different view of attitudes to life and death. Life was short, it could be very brutal. So the early mariners were very, um, phlegmatic about drowning. A lot of them deliberately would not learn to swim because they consider that should they be in the sea, it would just prolong their agony. Wow. I was actually going to ask if that was another kind of urban legend, but that is, that is, that's very true.
沉没。没有人会去考虑一旦开始沉没该如何救命。而且我们还要记住，当时人们对生死的态度是不同的。生命很短暂，而且可能非常残酷。所以早期的水手对溺水表现得非常……嗯，冷漠。他们中的许多人故意不去学游泳，因为他们认为如果掉进海里，学会游泳只会延长他们的痛苦。哇。我本来想问这是否又是某种都市传说，但那是真的，那是真的，非常真实。
That's very true. And it's the way things were. At least until 1785. That's when a British carriage builder named Lionel Lucan filed a patent for the world's first known boat designed with the specific purpose of saving lives at sea. Lucan's key innovation was to line the boat's hull with sealed air pockets and cork to help keep it buoyant, even in the most difficult conditions. It was just called an unemergible, a wonderful word, unemergible boat. Was his pamphlet for his patent? Yeah, it really rolls off the tongue in a late 18th century kind of way.
那是真的。这就是当时的情况。至少在1785年之前。那时，一位名叫莱昂内尔·卢坎的英国马车制造商为世界上第一艘已知专门用于海上救生的船申请了专利。卢坎的关键创新是在船体衬上密封的空气囊和软木，以帮助它保持浮力，即使在最困难的条件下也是如此。它被称为“不沉之舟”，一个美妙的词。那是他的专利小册子吗？是的，它在18世纪末的那种语境下确实朗朗上口。
Less than a decade later, the Englishmen William Woodhave and Henry Greathead improved on Lucan's design. Their boats all rose steeply upward at both ends so that only the middle of the boat would ever take on water while the bow and stern remained above the waterline, making it even more difficult to sink. It could also accommodate a crew of 12. Because when you get out to a wreck, you've got the wind and the weather,
不到十年后，英国人威廉·伍德黑夫和亨利·格雷特黑德改进了卢坎的设计。他们的船头和船尾都陡峭地向上翘起，这样只有船的中部会进水，而船头和船尾保持在水线以上，使它更难沉没。它还可以容纳12名船员。因为当你到达沉船地点时，你有风和天气的影响……
you've got lots of them and the place. So you're trying to manage the boat, keep the boat steady and have people there who can get somebody over the side of the boat. If you've ever tried to take a body, a live person out of the water over the side of a boat, you'll know what I mean. Not easy. But perhaps the most important improvement was that the boat wouldn't capsize. This was not just unemergeable, it would right itself as well. There's a difference between not sinking and also something that when it turns over, automatically rights itself. This is one of the earliest ideas for a self-writing boat.
你有很多人和那个地方。所以你要设法控制船只，保持船身平稳，并让船上的人能把人从船舷边拉上来。如果你曾经试过把一个活人从水里拉到船舷边，你就会明白我的意思。这并不容易。但也许最重要的改进是船不会倾覆。这不仅是“不沉”，它还能自动扶正。不沉和翻转后能自动扶正是有区别的。这是最早的自动扶正救生艇构想之一。
This is one of the earliest ideas for a self-writing boat. And somewhere along the way, these unemergible, self-writing, life-saving vessels were finally dubbed lifeboats. Now, you might think of a lifeboat as being, by definition, a boat that goes on a ship. But there still wasn't enough room for lifeboats on a ship's deck at this point. So instead, the earliest lifeboats were meant to be launched by people on shore, not unlike Coast Guard rescue boats today. That meant people on board a sinking ship still didn't have any reliable way to save themselves.
这是最早的自动扶正救生艇构想之一。在某个时候，这些不沉、自动扶正、救生用的船只终于被称为“救生艇”。现在，你可能会认为救生艇按定义就是放在船上的小艇。但在当时，船上的甲板上仍然没有足够的空间放置救生艇。因此，最早的救生艇实际上是由岸上的人发射的，就像今天的海岸警卫队救援艇一样。这意味着沉船上的人仍然没有任何可靠的方法来拯救自己。
But that changed in the mid-19th century when the age of sail gave way to the age of steam. A steamship's engine was tucked away inside its hull. With no sails or rigging to bother with, the deck could finally be put to other uses, including lifeboats. Transatlantic steamers also carried a lot more passengers. At first hundreds, and eventually thousands, many of them immigrants bound for the Americas. Did they bill it as safer than the sailing ships? Well, they know they didn't bill it necessarily as safer
但这种情况在19世纪中期发生了变化，当时帆船时代让位于蒸汽时代。蒸汽船的发动机被安置在船体内。没有了帆和索具的干扰，甲板终于可以用于其他用途，包括放置救生艇。跨大西洋轮船也运载了更多的乘客。起初是数百人，最终是数千人，其中许多是前往美洲的移民。他们是否宣传它比帆船更安全？嗯，他们知道他们不一定宣传它更安全……
because you've got to remember early steam ships did have a nasty propensity occasional to blow up, which slightly alarmed some people. And so with an eye towards customer safety, shipping companies slowly began putting more and more lifeboats on board. But what they found was that although lifeboats launched from shore performed well, lifeboats on ships were rarely able to save anyone.
因为你得记住，早期的蒸汽船确实偶尔有爆炸的恶劣倾向，这让一些人感到有些恐慌。因此，出于对客户安全的考虑，航运公司开始慢慢地在船上放置越来越多的救生艇。但他们发现，虽然从岸上发射的救生艇表现良好，但船上的救生艇却很少能救到人。
The simple fact was that the presence of lifeboats on a ship was no guarantee of survival. Mike Brady is a maritime history researcher and the creator of the YouTube channel Ocean Liner Designs. Mike says lifeboats on ships were only useful in ideal situations, when the water was calm and you were sinking slowly and close to land. But the rest of the time, lifeboats were a gamble. Shipboard lifeboats were more ungainly and cheaply built than their shore-based counterparts. They were designed to carry as many passengers as possible, not a rescue crew. And mariners quickly realized that it's one thing to send a boat into a raging sea from shore and pick up survivors.
简单的事实是，船上有救生艇并不能保证生存。迈克·布雷迪是一位海事历史研究员，也是YouTube频道“Ocean Liner Designs”的创作者。迈克说，船上的救生艇只有在理想情况下才有用，即水面平静、沉船缓慢且靠近陆地时。但在其他时候，救生艇就是一场赌博。船载救生艇比岸基救生艇更笨重、制造更廉价。它们的设计初衷是尽可能多地搭载乘客，而不是作为救援船。水手们很快意识到，从岸上向汹涌的大海派出小艇去接幸存者是一回事……
It's quite another to get people onto a boat from a moving deck and then lower that boat into the raging storm. It's just not happening because if a 400 foot long ship struggled, then you would not want to point to a relatively tiny 30 foot wooden boat and say, don't worry, this is what will save you. And if your ship was severely listing, that is, tilting too much to one side, then already you could only get half your boats off. The other half would get stuck against the ship's exposed hull, and even the boats you could lower would encounter some serious problems. Imagine the ships listing over about 15-20 degrees to one side, the boat is then swinging too far out,
而从移动的甲板上把人弄到小艇上，然后再把小艇降到汹涌的风暴中，则是另一回事。这根本行不通，因为如果一艘400英尺长的船都挣扎不已，你肯定不会指着一艘相对微小的30英尺木船说：“别担心，这就是能救你的东西。”如果你的船严重倾斜，也就是说向一侧倾斜得太厉害，那么你可能只能放下半数的救生艇。另一半会卡在船体暴露的一侧，即使是你能够放下的救生艇也会遇到严重的问题。想象一下船向一侧倾斜了大约15-20度，救生艇就会摆动得太远……
you've got boats that are being lowered down maybe successfully, but then being smashed back against the hull of the ship and spilling their occupants out into the sea. And that's if the crew didn't drop you. Which sometimes they did. An onboard lifeboat is generally attached with ropes to a crane called a davit. In those early days, the crew was supposed to lower the boat from the davit into the water by slowly letting the ropes out by hand. But a lifeboat could weigh multiple tons,
你放下的救生艇可能成功入水，但随后又被撞回船体，把船上的人甩进海里。这还是在船员没有把你掉下去的情况下。有时他们确实会掉下去。船载救生艇通常用绳索连接在一种叫“吊艇架”的起重机上。在那些早期日子里，船员本应通过手工缓慢地松开绳索，将救生艇从吊艇架降入水中。但一艘救生艇可能重达数吨……
and exhausted panic mariners could sometimes lose their grip. But the other part of it is that in order for lifeboats to actually work, in order for the theory to play out that passengers board these lifeboats and they've escaped the sinking of a ship, then the question is, now what? Even piloted by a trained crew member, a lifeboat was open topped at the mercy of the elements and often had few or no provisions.
而精疲力竭、惊慌失措的水手有时会抓不住。但另一部分原因是，为了让救生艇真正发挥作用，为了让“乘客登上救生艇并逃离沉船”的理论得以实现，那么问题来了：接下来怎么办？即使由训练有素的船员驾驶，救生艇也是敞篷的，任由风雨摆布，而且往往几乎没有或根本没有补给。
Okay if you're close to land, but not if you're far out at sea. Some of the concern was, well, is it going to be a good idea to have lots of people in small boats in the middle of the Atlantic when they're just going to be greater risk of exposure and less likelihood of being rescued? To what purpose? And plenty of lifeboats that did successfully get away from sinking ships simply disappeared or were found decades later washed up with their complement dead inside all over the world. But perhaps the worst case scenario was what happened to the SS Clallam, a small passenger steamer that ran into trouble in heavy seas off the coast of British Columbia.
如果你靠近陆地还可以，但如果你在远海就不行了。一些担忧是：在北大西洋中部让许多人待在小艇里，他们只会面临更大的暴露风险，获救的可能性也更小，这真的是个好主意吗？有什么意义呢？许多成功逃离沉船的救生艇要么消失了，要么几十年后被发现冲上岸，里面的人早已全部死亡。但也许最糟糕的情况发生在“SS Clallam”号上，这是一艘小型客轮，在不列颠哥伦比亚省海岸的汹涌海浪中遇到了麻烦。
Certain the ship was sinking, the men nobly lowered the women and children into the ship's only three lifeboats. Two tipped during lowering, the third capsized in the waves. All of the women and children died. Most of the men who stayed on board the ship were rescued the next morning. It's a shocking thing that to go for the lifeboat, to actually go for this thing that's designed
确信船要沉了，男人们高尚地将妇女和儿童放进了船上仅有的三艘救生艇中。两艘在下放过程中倾覆，第三艘在海浪中翻沉。所有的妇女和儿童都死了。留在船上的大多数男人在第二天早上获救。这是一件令人震惊的事情，去寻找救生艇，去寻找这个本应……
to save your life, seals your fate. And cements probably in the public mind a little bit when they see disasters like this that, yeah, the lifeboat is possibly useful in some scenarios, but probably stands as more of a symbol of absolute last resort, absolute, this is all we've got, rather than a tried and trusty safety feature that is your first option. If anything, lifeboats were kind of like the old-fashioned version of the life vest under your seat. Do you know if those things work? I don't either. You just hope it doesn't come to that.
拯救你生命的东西，反而注定了你的命运。这在公众心中巩固了一种印象：当他们看到这样的灾难时，是的，救生艇在某些情况下可能有用，但它可能更多地被视为一种绝对的最后手段，一种“这是我们仅有的东西”，而不是一种作为首选的、久经考验的安全功能。如果说有什么不同的话，救生艇就像是你座位下那种老式的救生衣。你知道那些东西管用吗？我也不知道。你只是希望别用到它。
But at the turn of the 20th century, the shipping industry hit upon a new strategy, one that would have long-term consequences for safety at sea. Because eventually as the technology is beginning to improve, shipping companies turned their focus to the ships themselves and the ship becomes the lifeboat. The ship becomes the lifeboat may sound like a contradiction in terms, but it marked a new paradigm in shipbuilding. The idea behind this new mantra, the ship is its own best lifeboat, was to make ships so sturdy, so reliable, with so many safety features and redundancies,
但在20世纪之交，航运业想出了一个新的策略，一个对海上安全产生深远影响的策略。因为最终，随着技术的进步，航运公司将注意力转向了船只本身，船本身就成了救生艇。“船本身就是救生艇”听起来可能自相矛盾，但它标志着造船业的一种新范式。这一新口号背后的理念是：船是它自己最好的救生艇。其目的是让船只变得如此坚固、如此可靠，并具备如此多的安全功能和冗余……
that there would rarely be any need to get in an actual lifeboat. Instead, in most emergencies, the safest boat would be the ship itself. In this new way of thinking, collisions were still best avoided, but they were ultimately OK, because these new ships could take a hit. Ships began to be constructed with stronger plated steel and with crucial redundancies such as double bottomed hulls. A hull would also have multiple compartments sealed with watertight bulkheads so that any flooding from a breach could be contained to a small area and the ship could stay afloat.
以至于几乎不需要用到真正的救生艇。相反，在大多数紧急情况下，最安全的船就是船本身。在这种新思维中，碰撞最好还是避免，但如果发生了也没关系，因为这些新船能承受撞击。船只开始用更坚固的钢板建造，并具备关键的冗余设计，如双层底船体。船体还会有多个用防水舱壁密封的隔舱，这样任何破损导致的进水都可以被限制在一个小区域内，船只就能保持漂浮。
Ships were also getting bigger, which made them stabler in rough seas. Size is definitely equated with safety. Tim Moulton is a historian, author and television presenter. And he says that ocean liner passengers, when given the choice, always went for the biggest, newest ships. Some of the immigrants traveling would only travel in a four funnel vessel because they would regard it as safer than a three funnel vessel and safer than a two funnel vessel and safer than a one funnel vessel. So it was
船只也变得越来越大，这使它们在汹涌的海面上更加平稳。尺寸绝对等同于安全。蒂姆·莫尔顿是一位历史学家、作家和电视节目主持人。他说，远洋客轮的乘客在有选择的情况下，总是会选择最大、最新的船。一些旅行的移民只会乘坐四烟囱的船，因为他们认为它比三烟囱的船更安全，比两烟囱的船更安全，也比一烟囱的船更安全。所以……
kind of like the more funnels you had the safer she was. And even if your big four funnel vessel did sink it was now more likely to sink slowly over the course of several hours instead of a few minutes. And that was no mistake. A lot of thought had gone into not just how the ship would behave in the event that she almost sinks, but actually how she would behave in the event that she did sink. Almost every new ocean liner in the early 20th century was described in casual conversation as unsinkable. But the ship's designers never totally believed it. Instead, they
就像烟囱越多，船就越安全一样。即使你那艘巨大的四烟囱船真的沉了，它现在也更有可能在几个小时内缓慢沉没，而不是几分钟。这绝非偶然。人们不仅考虑了船在几乎沉没时会如何表现，还考虑了它在真正沉没时会如何表现。20世纪初，几乎每一艘新的远洋客轮在日常谈话中都被描述为“永不沉没”。但船的设计师们从未完全相信这一点。相反，他们……
believed that in the last resort, a ship should be designed to sink well. But it wasn't just the ship that was safer. As more and more passenger vessels made their way across the Atlantic, the ocean itself was no longer a vast empty place with no other soul in sight. Tim says it was more like a busy freeway. And in fact, you couldn't go about anywhere you wanted on the North Atlantic. with no other soul in sight. Tim says it was more like a busy freeway. And in fact, you couldn't go about anywhere you wanted on the North Atlantic. There were very strict lanes,
相信作为最后的手段，船应该被设计成能“沉得好”。但不仅仅是船本身更安全。随着越来越多的客船穿过大西洋，海洋本身不再是一个空旷、看不见其他人影的地方。蒂姆说，它更像是一条繁忙的高速公路。事实上，你不能在北大西洋随心所欲地航行。蒂姆说，它更像是一条繁忙的高速公路。事实上，你不能在北大西洋随心所欲地航行。那里有非常严格的航道……
both for east-going traffic and west-going traffic, and those lanes were 60 miles apart. And the idea was that there would always be a ship coming along. But the linchpin that really made everything come together wasn't just bigger ships or stronger ships or subdivided ships or even more ships. It was that if your ship got into any trouble you could finally call for
无论是东行交通还是西行交通，这些航道相隔60英里。其理念是，总会有船经过。但真正让一切整合在一起的关键，不仅仅是更大的船、更坚固的船、分舱的船，甚至更多的船。而是如果你的船遇到任何麻烦，你终于可以呼叫……
help. The introduction of the Marconi wireless telegraph this cannot be overstated as being the biggest development probably in safety of life at sea at the time, because suddenly ships didn't have to be within visual distance. They could communicate with each other around the clock out to 400, 500 miles at nighttime. And it meant that suddenly the ships out at sea that were forming a vast highway formed basically a communications network. Now if your ship was sinking, a radio message could be sent out and picked up by nearby vessels in the ship's sea lane, who could then come to the rescue.
帮助。马可尼无线电报的引入，作为当时海上人命安全领域最大的发展，怎么强调都不为过，因为突然之间，船只不必保持在视距范围内。它们可以全天候地与彼此进行400到500英里范围内的通信。这意味着海上那些形成巨大高速公路的船只，基本上形成了一个通信网络。现在，如果你的船正在沉没，无线电信息可以发送出去，并被航道上附近的船只接收到，然后它们就可以前来救援。
And the idea becomes that if a ship does somehow start to sink, then it will sink slowly enough and evenly enough that help will be able to come and all the passengers will be able to be transferred off the vessel. But at the same time as all these innovations, perhaps even because of them, the design of shipboard lifeboats changed very little. Instead, they took on a far humbler and, frankly, more achievable role. Lifeboats were not an end destination.
其理念是，如果船真的开始沉没，它会沉得足够慢、足够平稳，这样救援就能赶到，所有乘客都能被转移下船。但与此同时，随着所有这些创新，甚至可能正是因为这些创新，船载救生艇的设计几乎没有改变。相反，它们承担了一个更卑微、坦率地说，更可行的角色。救生艇不是最终目的地。
Lifeboats were purely to ferry people to a nearby waiting liner. So even as ocean liners grew larger and larger, their builders never saw any need for a full complement of lifeboats. Between any two ships, there'd be enough, with plenty of time for them to make multiple trips between vessels. Now that the ship was its own lifeboat, the idea of providing simultaneous lifeboat space for everyone was never taken seriously. It's just considered ridiculous because you're relying on conditions actually even being
救生艇纯粹是为了将人们渡送到附近等待的班轮上。因此，即使远洋客轮越来越大，建造者们也从未觉得需要配备足额的救生艇。在任何两艘船之间，都会有足够的救生艇，并且有充足的时间让它们在船只之间往返多次。现在船本身就是救生艇，为所有人同时提供救生艇空间的构想从未被认真对待过。这被认为是很荒谬的，因为你依赖于当时的情况……
good enough to get everybody into the boats and to get those boats away safely and for those people to survive an extended period of time in open top boats, it seems so inconceivable there would ever be a scenario where all of those things happen. Until on April 14th 1912 They did That's after this And we're back with producer Joe Rosenberg. We like to tell a certain story about the Titanic. About human beings hubris.
足以让每个人都进入救生艇，让那些救生艇安全离开，并让那些人在敞篷救生艇中存活一段时间，似乎很难想象会有什么场景能让所有这些事情同时发生。直到1912年4月14日。它们发生了。那是在这之后。我们回来了，和制作人乔·罗森伯格在一起。我们喜欢讲述关于泰坦尼克号的某个故事。关于人类的傲慢。
About overconfident designers and reckless ship owners all drunk on a kind of unbridled pre-World War techno-optimism. And of course about how all that misplaced pride is the reason there weren't enough owners, all drunk on a kind of unbridled pre-World War techno-optimism. And of course about how all that misplaced pride is the reason there weren't enough lifeboats on the night the Titanic sank. And that's true. But it's also not the truth. These are not easy things to talk about what went wrong, right?
关于过度自信的设计师和鲁莽的船主，他们都沉醉于一种一战前肆无忌惮的技术乐观主义中。当然，还有关于所有那些错位的骄傲是如何导致泰坦尼克号沉没之夜救生艇不足的原因。这是事实。但它也不是真相。谈论哪里出了问题并不是一件容易的事，对吧？
Because all the things that people think went wrong, they did not go wrong. And they are not the things that went wrong. Both Tim Moulton and Mike Brady say there is a lot the standard narrative has backward, starting with the fact that as forms of travel go, the RMS Titanic, operated by White Star Lines and launched in April 1912, actually was exceptionally safe. Yeah, I mean, Joe, I don't want to shock the listeners, but I think the White Star Line and Titanic did pretty much everything right. Yeah, in 1912, there's absolutely no question that the Titanic was the best built and safest passenger ship to be on.
因为人们认为出了问题的所有事情，它们并没有出问题。而且它们也不是真正出了问题的地方。蒂姆·莫尔顿和迈克·布雷迪都说，标准叙事中有很多地方是颠倒的，首先，作为一种旅行方式，由白星航运公司运营并于1912年4月下水的泰坦尼克号，实际上是非常安全的。是的，我的意思是，乔，我不想让听众感到震惊，但我认为白星航运公司和泰坦尼克号几乎做对了一切。是的，在1912年，毫无疑问，泰坦尼克号是当时建造得最好、最安全的客轮。
All the lessons they'd put into place, all the lessons they'd learned the hard way from horrible loss of life, but then also the lessons they'd learned from when things went extremely well and Titanic was the culmination of all of this learning. Everything mentioned earlier, the double bottomed hull, the extensive compartmentalization, and the sheer size of Titanic, all of it worked to the ocean liner's advantage. As for lifeboats, it was well known that the requirements set by the British Board of Trade hadn't kept up with the size of the newest ships. To compensate, White Star Lines both reduced the total number of passengers on Titanic and added four additional collapsible lifeboats just in case.
他们所落实的所有经验教训，他们从可怕的生命损失中吸取的惨痛教训，以及从事情进展得非常顺利时学到的经验，泰坦尼克号是所有这些学习成果的结晶。前面提到的所有东西，双层底船体、广泛的分舱结构，以及泰坦尼克号的巨大尺寸，所有这些都对这艘远洋客轮有利。至于救生艇，众所周知，英国贸易委员会制定的要求并没有跟上最新船只的尺寸。为了弥补这一点，白星航运公司既减少了泰坦尼克号的总乘客人数，又增加了四艘额外的折叠式救生艇以防万一。
Taken all together, the Titanic really was its own best lifeboat. That didn't mean it couldn't sink. On the night of April 14, 1912, the passengers and crew of the Titanic all marveled at a North Atlantic ocean that was unusually calm, clear, and cold. Ice warnings had been issued from ships ahead of Titanic in the sea lane, so the crew were keeping a keen eye out for icebergs. At 11.39 p.m., Titanic's forward lookouts spotted an iceberg straight ahead. With the captain off duty, the course of action fell to the bridge's ranking officer.
总而言之，泰坦尼克号确实是它自己最好的救生艇。但这并不意味着它不会沉没。1912年4月14日晚，泰坦尼克号的乘客和船员都对北大西洋异常平静、清澈和寒冷的海面感到惊叹。海路上的前行船只已经发出了冰情警告，所以船员们一直在密切关注冰山。晚上11点39分，泰坦尼克号的前方瞭望员发现了正前方的冰山。由于船长不在岗，行动方案落到了舰桥值班军官的肩上。
What followed was a Rube Goldberg-like sequence of events that would see each of the Titanic's safety features defeated one by one. Starting with its compartmentalized steel hull, because under normal circumstances, the hull could have handled hitting the iceberg. So in the inquiry afterwards, it was asked what would have happened if Titanic had gone straight on into the iceberg without even trying to move left or right. And they calculated that Titanic would have stayed afloat. It would have squashed in her first few compartments, but it would be like a motor car putting on its brakes.
随之而来的是一系列鲁布·戈德堡式的事件，泰坦尼克号的每一项安全功能都被一一瓦解。从它的分舱钢制船体开始，因为在正常情况下，船体本可以应付撞击冰山的情况。所以在随后的调查中，有人问如果泰坦尼克号直接撞向冰山，甚至不尝试左右转向会发生什么。他们计算出泰坦尼克号会保持漂浮。它会压扁前几个隔舱，但这就像一辆汽车踩下刹车一样。
Except doing that, probably would have killed several dozen crew members. squashed in her first few compartments, but it would be like a motor car putting on its brakes. Except doing that probably would have killed several dozen crew members. So the Titanic's ranking officer on deck did something that likely made sense at the time. He ordered the crew to stop the engines and turn the ship in an effort to avoid a collision. But the maneuver was executed too late. And instead of missing the ship or colliding with it head on, the iceberg scraped along Titanic's right starboard side.
除了那样做，可能会导致几十名船员丧生。压扁前几个隔舱，但这就像一辆汽车踩下刹车一样。除了那样做，可能会导致几十名船员丧生。所以泰坦尼克号在甲板上的值班军官做了一件在当时看来可能合理的事情。他命令船员停止发动机并转向，试图避免碰撞。但这个动作执行得太晚了。结果没有避开船只，也没有正面碰撞，冰山沿着泰坦尼克号的右舷刮擦而过。
So Titanic was designed to have a collision with any vessel, however you like, okay? She was also designed to ram into a rock or something like that, or a lighthouse, or land, or a cliff. Or an iceberg. Exactly. But what she wasn't designed to do is have the kind of side swipe down the first 200 feet of the ship.
所以泰坦尼克号被设计成可以与任何船只发生碰撞，无论你喜欢哪种方式，好吧？她也被设计成可以撞向岩石或其他类似的东西，或者灯塔，或者陆地，或者悬崖。或者冰山。没错。但她没有被设计成可以沿着船的前200英尺发生那种侧面刮擦。
Those few hundred feet were one of the most vulnerable parts of Titanic, a section below the waterline, but above the ship's double-layered bottom. The iceberg ground against the single-layered hull, buckling the rivets between its steel plates. Water began leaking into several of Titanic's forward compartments. The Titanic could have up to four of her front compartments flooded and still not sink. An exceptional degree of redundancy.
那几百英尺是泰坦尼克号最脆弱的部分之一，位于水线以下，但在船的双层底之上。冰山磨擦着单层船体，使钢板之间的铆钉弯曲。水开始渗入泰坦尼克号的几个前部隔舱。泰坦尼克号最多可以有四个前部隔舱进水而不沉没。这是一种卓越的冗余度。
And in fact, the damage wasn't that much. The problem with the damage was that it was into that crucial fifth compartment. So that, unfortunately, that was her Achilles heel in the sense of it was outside her design envelope. One by one, the five compartments began to flood. And that meant that the weight of water in the first five compartments, they dragged the Titanic down by the bow. And then if you imagine like an ice cube tray that you're filling with water, what happened was that as they pulled down the top of the bulkhead in the next compartment, the water would overflow into the next and the next and the next. Eventually all of the compartments would be compromised. The Titanic was going to sink.
事实上，损坏并没有那么严重。损坏的问题在于它进入了关键的第五个隔舱。所以，不幸的是，那是她的阿喀琉斯之踵，因为它超出了她的设计包络线。五个隔舱开始一个接一个地进水。这意味着前五个隔舱中水的重量将泰坦尼克号的船头拖了下去。如果你想象一个你正在注水的冰格，发生的情况是，当它们拉低下一个隔舱的舱壁顶部时，水会溢出到下一个，再下一个，再下一个。最终所有的隔舱都会受损。泰坦尼克号注定要沉没。
But the Titanic wasn't totally defeated yet. Because as expected, there was another ship in Titanic's ceiling, close enough to come to the rescue, the Californian. The Titanic's captain had already ordered the radio operator to send out a distress signal strong enough for the Californian to hear. From there, the rescue effort was supposed to play out calmly and rationally, just as it had with other recent sinkings. What's interesting is, in 1912, there was no 24-hour radio watch. And unfortunately, the radio operator of the Californian had actually turned in for the night just before Titanic sent a distress signal.
但泰坦尼克号还没有完全被击败。因为正如预期的那样，泰坦尼克号的航道上还有另一艘船，近到足以前来救援，那就是“加利福尼亚人号”。泰坦尼克号的船长已经命令无线电操作员发出足够强的求救信号，让“加利福尼亚人号”能够听到。从那里开始，救援工作本应冷静而理性地进行，就像最近的其他沉船事件一样。有趣的是，在1912年，没有24小时的无线电值班。不幸的是，“加利福尼亚人号”的无线电操作员在泰坦尼克号发出求救信号前不久刚刚休息。
Shipboard radios were still a new technology. At the time, their focus was on transmitting private correspondence. It just hadn't occurred to anyone yet that no one would be listening when a ship was in trouble. Against all planning and odds, everything now hinged on Titanic's last and least reliable line of defense, its lifeboats. And let's be clear, this is not the part of the story where the lifeboats come in and save the day and all of their weaknesses turn out to be strengths. The lifeboats did what lifeboats normally did. They f***ing sucked.
船载无线电在当时还是一项新技术。当时，它们的重点是传输私人信件。当时还没人想到，当一艘船遇到麻烦时，可能根本没人会听。违背了所有的计划和几率，一切现在都取决于泰坦尼克号最后也是最不可靠的防线：它的救生艇。我们要明确一点，这不是故事中救生艇出现并拯救一切，所有弱点都变成优点的部分。救生艇做了救生艇通常做的事。它们烂透了。
The Titanic's crew had never performed a lifeboat drill at sea, and when the women and children were ordered to abandon ship, the ship's davit system for launching the lifeboats turned out to be incredibly difficult to operate. Passengers hustled onto the deck on a freezing moonless night, watched as the tiny open-topped boats jerked and creaked and banged against the hull on their long way down to the invisible water eight stories below. Understandably, at first, most people refused to get on them. And while the lifeboats were glitching their way down to the water, the Titanic was doing its job. It was sinking well. Maybe, if anything, too well.
泰坦尼克号的船员从未在海上进行过救生艇演习，当妇女和儿童被命令弃船时，船上的救生艇下放系统变得极其难以操作。乘客们在寒冷、无月的夜晚涌上甲板，看着那些微小的敞篷小艇在长达八层楼的下放过程中，在通往看不见的水面的路上猛烈地晃动、吱吱作响并撞击着船体。可以理解的是，起初大多数人拒绝上船。当救生艇在下放过程中出现故障时，泰坦尼克号正在履行它的职责。它沉得很好。也许，如果说有什么的话，是沉得太好了。
Her design had been that she would sink evenly and slowly, and that's exactly what Titanic does. So the ship is sinking very very slightly so passengers can't tell that it's sinking. So actually Titanic looks at this time absolutely fine. She's warm, the lights are on, the band is playing, people are having drinks at the bar. Why would I take that risk of going in a in a tiny rowing boat when I can clearly take my chances with the biggest ship in the world. Making matters worse, word had spread among the passengers that a distress signal had
她的设计是她会平稳而缓慢地沉没，而这正是泰坦尼克号所做的。所以船沉得非常非常轻微，以至于乘客们无法察觉它正在沉没。所以实际上泰坦尼克号此时看起来完全没问题。她很温暖，灯火通明，乐队在演奏，人们在酒吧里喝酒。当我可以清楚地选择乘坐世界上最伟大的船时，我为什么要冒着风险去坐一艘微小的划艇呢？更糟糕的是，乘客中传言说求救信号已经……
gone out. They didn't yet understand that the only ship close enough had never received it. Everything around the passengers flashed the same reassuring and now familiar message over and over again. The ship was what was safe. The ship was what was safe. The ship was the lifeboat. The passengers' faith in the ship made an already terrible situation even worse. With most people refusing to board the lifeboats, the first took off only half loaded.
发出去了。他们还不知道唯一足够近的船根本没有收到它。乘客周围的一切都闪烁着同样令人安心且现在很熟悉的信号，一遍又一遍。船是安全的。船是安全的。船就是救生艇。乘客对船的信任使本已糟糕的情况变得更糟。由于大多数人拒绝登上救生艇，第一艘救生艇出发时只装了一半人。
One boat with a capacity of 40 was launched with seven crew members and just five passengers. Only when the deck's sharpening angle became obvious did the thousands of passengers still on board. Many who had just arrived on deck from second and third class scrambled to save themselves. The surge caused the later round of lifeboats to go off severely overloaded. In the rush, the ropes for lowering one of the boats got stuck and had to be sawed through by hand with a penknife. A different boat barely avoided being crushed
一艘载客量为40人的救生艇在下水时只有7名船员和5名乘客。只有当甲板的倾斜角度变得明显时，船上成千上万的乘客，许多刚从二等舱和三等舱来到甲板的人，才争先恐后地自救。这种激增导致后来的救生艇严重超载。在匆忙中，下放其中一艘救生艇的绳索卡住了，不得不由人用小刀手工锯断。另一艘救生艇险些被压碎……
when another was almost lowered on top of it. Another flipped over before entering the water, and some passengers attempted to jump onto boats from the deck above and missed. But all of that only served to mask a more fundamental problem. So the question is, would more boats have made a difference? I think there were enough crew to get the boats away, but the time was so narrow and so limited. In fact, the crew
当另一艘救生艇差点被降在它上面时。还有一艘在入水前翻了，一些乘客试图从上面的甲板跳到救生艇上却没跳中。但所有这些都只是掩盖了一个更根本的问题。所以问题是，更多的救生艇会有所不同吗？我认为有足够的船员来放下救生艇，但时间太紧迫、太有限了。事实上，船员……
worked so hard, even though it was literally freezing outside, Second Officer Charles Lighthaller, he was soaked with sweat to get all the boats away. So the crew worked like absolute lions, but they still just ran out of time. The lifeboat simply took too long to lower into the water. Ultimately, the crew was only just able to set off the last of the regular boats and two of the spare collapsible boats that Titanic's designers added earlier. The last two collapsibles were never launched. Even with better training, the crew could only have launched a handful more boats. Nowhere near enough for the 1,500 people still on board.
工作得非常努力，尽管外面冷得要命，二副查尔斯·莱托勒浑身湿透，汗流浃背地试图放下所有的救生艇。所以船员们像狮子一样努力工作，但他们还是耗尽了时间。救生艇下放到水面实在花了太长时间。最终，船员们勉强放下了最后一艘常规救生艇和泰坦尼克号设计师之前增加的两艘备用折叠艇。最后两艘折叠艇从未下水。即使有更好的训练，船员们也只能多放下几艘救生艇。离船上剩下的1500人所需的人数还差得远。
So I don't see there being enough time. You're not going to be getting 40 or 50 boats off Titanic in the space of an hour. The truth is, no number or arrangement of lifeboats was going to work. But when the survivors were picked up later that morning and the world learned what had happened, none of this mattered. Because the same implausible sequence of events that made Titanic look bad, made lifeboats look great. And the reason for that is that the only people that were rescued from the Titanic were all in lifeboats.
所以我认为没有足够的时间。你不可能在一小时内放下40或50艘救生艇。事实是，无论救生艇的数量或安排如何，都无济于事。但当幸存者在当天晚些时候被救起，全世界得知发生了什么事时，这一切都不重要了。因为那一系列让泰坦尼克号看起来很糟糕的不可思议的事件，却让救生艇看起来很棒。原因在于，从泰坦尼克号上获救的唯一一批人都在救生艇里。
What most people didn't realize, including many survivors, was that this was only because of the very particular conditions of that one night. Instead of the normally rough North Atlantic waters in which lifeboats often floundered, the ocean on the night of the sinking was universally described as a sea of glass. They didn't know it, but this was life-saving for the survivors crowded into small, open-topped, severely overloaded boats. Meanwhile, the ocean water, which freezes at a lower temperature than freshwater, was
大多数人没有意识到的是，包括许多幸存者在内，这仅仅是因为那一晚非常特殊的条件。海洋在沉没之夜被普遍描述为“玻璃之海”，而不是通常汹涌的北大西洋水域，救生艇经常在那种水域中挣扎。他们不知道，这对挤在小型、敞篷、严重超载的救生艇里的幸存者来说是救命的。与此同时，冰点比淡水低的海洋水……
28 degrees Fahrenheit. Of the people with life jackets who did not make it onto a lifeboat before the ship sank, only a tiny handful survived. One gentleman had strapped himself to a door, another one was on a staircase that was floating. In other words, people who'd managed to keep themselves out of the water, they were still alive. Oh, so someone really did survive on a door.
是华氏28度。在船沉没前，那些穿着救生衣但没能登上救生艇的人中，只有极少数幸存者。一位绅士把自己绑在了一扇门上，另一位在漂浮的楼梯上。换句话说，那些设法让自己不接触水的人，他们还活着。哦，所以真的有人在门上幸存了下来。
That's not just movie magic. No, that is one of the true things in the film. was still alive. Oh, so someone really did survive on a door. That's not just movie magic. No, that is one of the true things in the film. In the immediate wake of the disaster, the stark math of who survived and who didn't provided the Titanic story with a simple moral. Lifeboats meant life. Never mind the fact, of course, that were conditions to be any different, Titanic's boats probably wouldn't have performed as well.
那不仅仅是电影特效。不，那是电影中真实的事情之一。还活着。哦，所以真的有人在门上幸存了下来。那不仅仅是电影特效。不，那是电影中真实的事情之一。在灾难发生后的第一时间，谁幸存谁没幸存的残酷数学为泰坦尼克号的故事提供了一个简单的道德教训。救生艇意味着生命。当然，别忘了，如果条件有任何不同，泰坦尼克号的救生艇可能表现得就不会那么好了。
The big lesson gets distilled down to if there had been more lifeboats on Titanic, more people would have survived. It's impossible to overstate just how quickly this belief took hold in the public imagination after the Titanic disaster. That if a ship got into trouble, your best way to survive was to get on a lifeboat. And therefore, it was critical that a ship have enough lifeboats for every person on board. Ship designers and veteran seamen of the time knew that in most scenarios, onboard lifeboats
大教训被提炼为：如果泰坦尼克号上有更多的救生艇，更多的人就会幸存。在泰坦尼克号灾难后，这种信念在公众想象中扎根的速度之快，怎么强调都不为过。即如果船遇到麻烦，你最好的生存方式就是登上救生艇。因此，船上必须有足够所有人使用的救生艇，这一点至关重要。当时的船舶设计师和资深海员都知道，在大多数情况下，船载救生艇……
remained of only limited use. But it didn't matter. Two weeks after the Titanic sank, the crew of another white star ocean liner actually went on strike, refusing to work until the ship carried enough lifeboats for everyone. Yeah, so it's a full-blooded mutiny, but it was a statement. If there aren't enough boats for all of us, we're not going to work. And that had not happened before. You know, the crews of ships hadn't really thought that way ever. So it is a huge
仍然用途有限。但这并不重要。泰坦尼克号沉没两周后，另一艘白星航运公司远洋客轮的船员竟然举行了罢工，拒绝工作，直到船上配备了足够所有人的救生艇。是的，这是一场彻底的兵变，但它是一种声明。如果没有足够的救生艇供我们所有人使用，我们就不会工作。这在以前从未发生过。你知道，船员们以前从未这样想过。所以这是一个巨大的
departure and a huge shift towards awareness for safety for all at sea, not just for passengers. In 1914, just two years later, an international treaty made the practice of lifeboats for all mandatory. That treaty, called SOLUS for safety of life at sea sea has been signed by 168 countries and is still in effect today. Ironically that requirement is more useful now than it was in 1914. The world may have learned the wrong lesson from Titanic but since then lifeboat technology has caught up with our expectations. They're still only to be used as a last resort. Even now, the ship remains its own best lifeboat. But modern lifeboats can be launched faster and are far safer on the water
转折，也是海上安全意识的巨大转变，不仅是为了乘客，也是为了所有人。1914年，仅仅两年后，一项国际条约规定必须为所有人配备救生艇。该条约名为《海上人命安全公约》（SOLAS），已由168个国家签署，至今仍然有效。讽刺的是，这一要求现在比1914年更有用。世界可能从泰坦尼克号中学到了错误的教训，但从那时起，救生艇技术已经赶上了我们的期望。它们仍然只能作为最后的手段使用。即使在今天，船只本身仍然是最好的救生艇。但现代救生艇的下水速度更快，在水面上也远比
than their 20th century predecessors. And on very rare occasions, having enough lifeboats for everyone has actually proven crucial. So I guess even if it's not the lesson we should have learned from the Titanic, in the final analysis, it turns out everyone really does deserve a spot on a lifeboat. Even Jack. I really think there's only one question to ask when it comes to Titanic, which is, was there space for Jack on that door? Would he have taken them both down with him? I like that. James Cameron took that so seriously.
20世纪的前辈们更安全。在极少数情况下，拥有足够的救生艇确实被证明是至关重要的。所以我猜，即使这不是我们应该从泰坦尼克号中学到的教训，归根结底，每个人确实都应该在救生艇上占有一席之地。即使是杰克。我真的认为在谈到泰坦尼克号时只有一个问题要问，那就是，那扇门上还有杰克的空间吗？他会把他们两个都带下去吗？我喜欢这一点。詹姆斯·卡梅隆非常认真地对待这个问题。
He tested it recently with two actors in a tank. He did? Oh, I didn't know this. He did. He did. He got a replica of the panel and two people about the same size as Jack and Rose and found conclusively that two people on the panel survived.
他最近在水箱里用两名演员进行了测试。他做了吗？哦，我不知道这一点。他做了。他做了。他弄到了一个面板的复制品，还有两个和杰克与露丝体型差不多的人，并最终得出结论，面板上的两个人都能幸存。
I knew it. I knew it. I knew it the whole time. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Joe Rosenberg and edited by Losh Madon. Additional editing by Kelly Prime. Mixed by Martín González. Music by Swan Real and George Langford. Fact-checking by Graham Hayesha. Special thanks this week to our guest, Helen Doe.
我就知道。我一直都知道。我一直都知道。《99% Invisible》本周由乔·罗森伯格制作，洛什·马登编辑。凯利·普莱姆进行了额外编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。音乐由斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德创作。格雷厄姆·海耶沙进行事实核查。本周特别感谢我们的嘉宾海伦·多伊。
Helen's book, One Crew, is a history of the first ever nationwide lifeboat service, Britain's Royal National Lifeboat Institution. We ended up cutting a whole section of this story about the RNLI's incredible history, so we strongly recommend you check out Helen's book. We'll have links to that as well as more work from Tim Moulton and Mike Brady's YouTube channel Ocean Liner Designs on our website. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes
海伦的书《一个船员》是世界上第一个全国性救生艇服务机构——英国皇家全国救生艇协会（RNLI）的历史。我们最终删减了关于RNLI不可思议历史的整个部分，所以我们强烈建议你去看看海伦的书。我们将在我们的网站上提供相关链接，以及蒂姆·莫尔顿和迈克·布雷迪的YouTube频道“远洋客轮设计”的更多作品。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括
Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites,
克里斯·贝鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·雷、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，
mostly Blue Sky these days, as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
最近主要是Blue Sky，以及我们自己的Discord服务器。在99PI.org上有该链接以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。